so this is what cardi B just said
yesterday she said well well well
you know about Andrew Tate and his
brother being arrested right cardi B now
here here's here's the crazy part while
she's saying this okay here's a crazy
part while she's saying this Rob pull up
this article from CNN I just sent you
cardi B pull up the article from seeing
I just literally I just texted it to you
pull that one up I love what you said
about cardi B yeah let's talk about that
but I want you to see this here real
quick right after what she just said so
this is a story from CNN cardi B admits
to drugging Robin men years ago admits
admitted admitted it so do you have the
whole story do you have the whole story
to click on it like the one I sent you
or uh um because Pat this is the one
where she's she's and she's admitting
when she was stripping that she would
literally take guys out yeah drug them
yeah drug them and then Rob the [ __ ] out
of them and you have no idea as he's
looking for a pen I posted uh something
about this you should see the the the
the people coming after me on Instagram
where they were like hey you weren't in
her life you don't know what she was
going through in that moment I go what
what the heck you don't know what it's
like to be a stripper yeah yeah no not
even that and then and then Pat just
recently she does a video in her car
she's like guess what if my man cheats
on me you know what I'm gonna do I'm
like I'm gonna grab a girl we're gonna
take him out I'm gonna get him all drugs
on Percocet we're gonna go and have a
threesome but she's not gonna be a girl
it's gonna be a guy a [ __ ] and then
guess what haha we got you this is cardi
B this is her yeah because I'm just drug
the robin so go a little closer today
cardi B took on Instagram to
contextualize and express regretful
claim she made in a video from three
years ago in the resurface Instagram
live video the rapper claimed that
during her days as a stripper she lured
men to a hotel rooms for sex but then
drugged them and Rob them instead I'm a
part of hip-hop culture where you can
talk about where you came from talk
about the wrong things you've done and
where you are she wrote in a note on
Instagram and it's true she hardly uh
the first rapper had to have a criminal
password there are rappers that glorify
murder violence drugs and robbing crimes
they feel they had to do to survive I
never glorified the things that I
brought up in the live in that live I
never put up those things in music
because I'm not proud of it and felt
responsibly not too glorified I mean
there was a movie made about her by the
way you guys the JLo played you don't
remember the movie that James said last
two years yeah so she was I mean that
she said yeah she's in the movie and and
partly that's her story it's partly her
story but here's the thing cardi B no
one is saying that you know the hip-hop
culture the past we don't understand we
all listen to the similar type of
hip-hop music all people are saying is
the following
you don't earn the right to say this
because you're a hypocrite that's the
only reason nothing more nothing less
you sound like a hypocrite as if
somebody that walked on water and you
got up to where you are today by playing
some of those games if not worse and you
admitted to it
this man's being accused of it now
whether he did it or not the courts are
going to do their part but this is where
you lose some credibility when you're
saying what you're saying well the no
one of the major messages that Tate
talks about is is this new wave feminism
okay so I think we can all agree I mean
there's been like three waves of
feminism it was the first wave feminism
where like women suffrage right to vote
of course who wouldn't want that second
wave feminism is right like you know
right to work be in the workplace not
get sexually harassed totally makes
sense this new wave third wave feminism
I'm a boss babe like I Don't Need No Man
like the cardi B WAP whole situation
well I mean he calls these people out
left and right yeah and that there's no
wonder that the cardi B's of the world
yeah so I I don't know if that article
was a misspelling that instead of rapper
it actually wrote Raper because what
she's done in her past is but he's
calling out this these high body count
hoe ass [ __ ] women who are being
apostolized by new woke feminists like I
can have sex with as many men as I want
there's no repercussions for my actions
I can do what I want to do it's like
these are the examples that they're
setting for women today of course that's
the same same as those overly or
morbidly obese people like lizard
they're like she's a hero yeah she has
courage
yeah she's literally she's got diabetics
yeah yeah and and then and it goes to my
other point too it's like Pat mind you
this cardi B and this has been out for a
long long time she's the same girl that
sat down with the uh with Joe Biden they
interviewed like they were like you know
what let's use her to get votes they
don't give a [ __ ] just like Bernie
Sanders too think about this Bernie
Sanders and the president of the United
States sat down and had a real
one-on-one with cardi B an openly
drugging module if there's any guys out
there that were drugged or Rabbi come
forward because if she did it for you
please come say something believe oh man
believe me
men like should they use her think about
it they use her to get the minority vote
and they don't give a [ __ ] she doesn't
give a damn
hypocrite yeah I mean look to me you did
what you did you made your money you
know just as the mindset of a
Libertarian is do what you got to do to
make your money don't break the law
don't do anything to make your money but
she made her money breaking the law any
of that stuff if she got caught doing
that that is a rape that you're taking
advantage of not necessarily rape that's
called robbery you're stealing money
from people yeah you can go to jail for
that but she's forgiven so again all of
this goes back to a guy called out
the BS on the establishment and they're
not happy about it and they got to take
them down it's that simple there's calls
that are saying this guy's getting
louder and louder and louder stop him
now before he gets more momentum so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]